ariana grande drops the mic on blake
shelton after becoming the first coach
to fill her team on season 21 of the
voice i'm happy life is good
on tuesday ari was totally blown away by
sister trio kck3
who took the stage with a harmonized
rendition of her 2018 hit no tears left
to cry
[Music]
yeah ari she loved it and turned her
chair around like immediately
it was like so crazy as for the other
coaches kelly clarkson blake shelton and
john legend they knew they didn't stand
a chance so they left ari to swoop up
the musicians for her team this is the
kindest thing y'all have ever done for
me
i think there's an obvious reason here
why none of us turned around
first of all i got so excited because i
love harmonies i didn't even realize it
was my song at first you are the last of
my slots on my team
i fell in love with their voices i
cannot wait to pick songs with them the
seven ring singer took the stage to
celebrate and capped off the moment with
a mic drop right in front of blake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and with a full team ari is proving to
be a real threat this season something
john kelly and blake all admitted to e.t
leading up to the season 21 premiere
she's a threat she is hugely talented
hugely successful and has legions and
legions of fans that know how to use the
internet and vote
everything he just said
so we all knew it coming in i was
prepared i came with in battle armor
i'm prepared to be turned down just
being new there's so much to learn but i
feel like i just get to learn watching
them and it's been amazing
[Music]